Now we turn to our last example
of dynamic programming, and
consider the problem of
finding shortest paths between
all pairs of vertices in the graph.
If you're resting on ideas like paths
and graphs, or Dijkstra's algorithm, it
might help to review these ideas before
proceeding with this part of the lesson.
Note that the idea of shortest,
is given in terms of weights or
costs on the edges.
These might be negative, so
we don't refer to them as lengths or
distances themselves to avoid confusion.
But we retain the word
shortest with regards to path,
instead of saying lightest or cheapest.
Unfortunately, the use of this
mixed metaphor is standard.
We're given a graph G and a weight is
associated with every edge in the graph.
And our goal is to find a shortest path
between every pair u and v in the graph.
That is to say,
a path that minimizes the sum of
the weights involved in the path.
Note that the idea of shortest here,
is in terms of these weights.
These weights might be negative, so
we don't refer to them as lengths or
distances to try to avoid confusion.
But on the other hand, we still
refer to the paths as the shortest,
instead of saying lightest or cheapest.
Unfortunately, the use of this
mixed metaphor is standard.
Recall that for the single source
problem, where we want to figure out
the shortest path from one vertex to all
others, we can use Dijkstra's Algorithm.
Which takes V times log V plus E time,
when used with the Fibonacci cube.
But this algorithm requires that
the weights all be non-negative,
an assumption that we
don't want to make.
For graphs with negative weights,
the standard single-source solution
is the Bellman-Ford algorithm,
which takes order V times E time.
Now we can run these
algorithm multiple times.
Once with each vertex as the source.
If we visualize the problem of finding
the shortest path between all pairs,
as filling out a grid like this one.
Then Dijkstra or
Bellman-Ford would correspond to
filling out this one row at a time.
One call to the algorithm to
fill out one row of the table.
This strategy involves running
each of these algorithms v times.
So we could just add a factor
of v to their running times,
to get the all pairs
shortest path version.
Where the weights are non-negative,
this strategy of using Dijkstra's
algorithm is quite competitive.
For the case where the weights
could be negative, however, and
especially when the graph is dense,
we're looking at
an algorithm that is on the order of
v to the fourth for Bellman-Ford.
Using dynamic programming,
we're going to be able to do better.